gardening is my graffiti I grow my art I
beautify lines Parkways I use the guard
in the soil like it's a piece of cloth
in the in the plants and the in the
trees that that's my embellishment for
that cloth I live in a food desert so me
and my group La green grounds we got
together and we started planting my food
for us fruit trees you know the whole
knife I have witnessed my garden become
a tool for the education a tool for the
transformation of my neighborhood
to change the community you have to
change the composition of the soil we
are the soil I want us all to become
evolutionary Renegades gangsters
gangster gardeners what I'm talking
about is putting people to work and
getting and getting kids off the street
and letting them know the joy the pride
and the honor in growing your own food